[Music]
welcome to
fers Welcome to My Channel today we are
harvesting orra follow along and see the
way we did
it as you we observe we will realize
that the okra is planted amidst other
crops it is a mix cropping that we have
as you can observe it here see the okra
you see some um
a very young uh corn likewise you see
Caba in form of a mixed cropping so it's
not only okra that is there as you can
see yes so it's mixed cropping see the
bigger okra
here and then some uh Little Corn they
also there so it is mixed croing so
right now we want to do some harvesting
of the okra for follow along and watch
to the end and see what we can also
achieve apart from eating the okra
fruits
so
coming as you can see we were using
knife to cut the orra fruits not just
cutting them by mere hands what
is see to the
end check
ERS check ERS see any other
one right
now there are no more okay let's check
other
plants no
more okay we have
here all right
now if you don't Harvest them on time
they become too hard and not suitable
for eating any longer they must be fresh
and soft for them to be suitable for
eating otherwise you leave them like
that to mature and dried
up you may leave them to mature and dry
up such as this ones it become too hard
like this one now you may leave them on
the plant and let it dry up for
preservation of seeds for
planting in another planting season okay
when it dries up and the seeds be ready
for planting in another planting
season but for consumption they have to
be soft and not hard so for you to be
usedful cooking okay
[Music]
okay